a new free voluntary covid testing
program was approved last week for clark
county school district employees but it
comes with a few requirements
a news now reporter kristen drummond
shows us the stipulations
the funding for this cova testing
program is state allocated from federal
cares act dollars and
has some provisions like most of the
cares dollars there's
a it's time sensitive it has to be used
or you lose it an agreement with an
expiration date
in this case it's december 31st john
valerdina with the clark county
education association
says the district has six weeks to start
the program
as of right now the question of
implementation is really in the school
district's hands as to when do they want
to start having this program kick in the
executive director of the teachers union
adds
it requires staff to be in buildings the
district transitioned most employees
last week to work from home
telecommuting will continue through the
end of the semester
and if there is no program that's
implemented then that money basically
goes away
the board of trustees approved a
memorandum of agreement between the
school district and
tht health last week for the task force
initiative for educators safety and
screening
also known as ties tht health partnered
with the nevada department of education
to launch the covet testing and health
screenings for public school employees
statewide
all funded by roughly 13 million dollars
in federal relief funds
i would have liked to have had more
information about other
school districts despite some members
concerns valerdina calls the action a
step in the right direction
when it comes to ccsd employee safety
kristin drummond
8 news now kristin thank you there is a
scheduled meeting on wednesday between
ccea ccsd and the teachers health trust
regarding
the next steps now vella dorito remains
optimistic about another round of cares
act funding for next year
if that happens he expects a certain
amount allocated for public schools
which may help continue the free covet
testing for educators